[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم في حصه
الليله معكم محمد كريشاني في هذه اللحظات
مدن وعواصم في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث
مميزه البدايه من ميامي عاصمه النيجر التي
تعيش على وقع قرار من الاتحاد الافريقي
بتعليق عضويتها بسبب الانقلاب وكذلك على
وقع تصريحات لرئيس وفد اكواس الذي زار
النيجر قبل ايام بان زيارته تلك كانت
مثمره للغايه
وهذه صور مباشره من نيويورك التي شهدت
اليوم جلسه لمجلس الامن الدولي بشان
الاوضاع في ليبيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد بهذه الليله
في قرار تصعيدي لمجلس السلم والامني في
الاتحاد الافريقي تعليق عضويه النيجر وبحث
التداعيات المحتمله للتدخل العسكري ماني
يحذر من تفكك اكواس اذا اتجهت لانهاء
الانقلاب في النيابه بالقوه وواشنطن تؤكد
العمل مع شراءها لاستعاده الديمقراطيه في
النيجر
[موسيقى]
قوات الاحتلال تعتقد منفذي عمليه قتلت
فيها مستوطنه في الخليل مصدر في حماس يقول
للجزيره انهما عدوان في الحركه والطاقم
الامني المصغر يخول رئيس الوزراء ووزير
الدفاع توجيه ضربات لمنفذي العمليات
ومموليهم
سلاح المدرعات في الخرطوم ساحه معارك
محتدمه بين الجيش والدعم السريع الجيش
يعلن سيطرته على المعسكر بعد مواجهات
امتدت لثلاثه ايام ويقود اشتباكات عنيفه
في شمال ام درمان وجنوبها وفرار عشرات
الالاف من المعارك في نيالا جنوب دارفور
مسيرات تستهدف مواقع في موسكو والقوات
الروسيه تعلن صده ثلاث هجمات بريه على
محور شرقا
تؤكد ان امد الحرب يتوقف على دعم الشركاء
ومصدر اوروبي يكشف عن تحضير بوريل
لمحادثات بنيويورك بشان السلام في
اوكرانيا
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم قرر مجلس السلم
والامن التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي تعليق
عضويه النيجر في كل انشطه الاتحاد فورا
حتى استعاده النظام الدستوري هناك
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي والسؤال الذي يقول ما
احتمال وتفعيل قرار اقواس بالتدخل العسكري
النتائج جاءت على النحو التالي نحو
31% قالوا ان احتمال تفعيل القرار اكثر
ترجيحا في حين قال 69 بالمئه ان تفعيل
قرار اكواس بالتدخل العسكري يبقى اقل
ترجيحا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقاء على منصات الرقميه يتجدد كالعاده
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
انطلاق اعمال قمه مجموعه بريكس في جهان
سبورت دعوه روسيه الى التخلي عن الدولار
وجنوب افريقيا تعلن بحث توسيع المجموعه
[موسيقى]
البدايه بالقرار التصعيدي الذي اتخذه مجلس
السلم والامن في الاتحاد الافريقي بشان
النيجر اذ قرر تعليق عضويه ميامي مع بحث
التداعيات المحتمله لتدخل مجموعه اكواس
عسكريا وهو تدخل حذرت مالي من انه قد يفكك
المجموعه ان وقع في الاثناء قالت
ملتزمه باعاده الامور الى ما كانت عليه في
النيجر وانها لا تعمل او انها تعمل
بالاحرى مع شركائها لاستعاده الديمقراطيه
هناك
لا مكان لكم بيننا هذا قرار فوري يخص به
الاتحاد الافريقي قاده الانقلاب في النيجر
اخيرا اجمع مجلس الامن والسلم التابع
للاتحاد على تعليق مشاركه البلد المطاحي
برئيسه في جميع انشطه المنظمه القاريه هل
سيتاثر حكام النيجر الحاليون بالقرار لا
شك في ان العزله القاريه ايا كان شكلها لا
تخدمهم غير ان تعليق العضويه لم يفيد
كثيرا فيما يرى مراقبون في حالات مشابهه
هي مالي وبوركينا فاسو والسودان ثم ان
عقابا كهذا ليس في وزن استخدام القوه
العسكريه لاعاده البلد المعني الى المسار
الدستوري
ما زالت المساله كما يبدو محل تجاذبات
افريقيه
مجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي قال انه يدرس
قرار ايكوس تحضير قوات لنشرها في النيجر
وان المفوضيه الافريقيه ستقيم تداعياته
ذلك
تضامنه الكامل مع بشان ما يقول انه
التزامها باستعاده النظام الدستوري في
النيجر عبر الوسائل الدبلوماسيه لا يعرف
هنا على وجه الدقه ما اذا كان الاتحاد
سيمضي على خطى المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
غربيه افريقيا ام انه يبقى على مسافه من
ترتيباتها الحاليه والمستقبليه
تفضل نهج الحوار وتتواصل مع انقلابيين بل
وتصف الزياره وفيها الاخيره الى هناك
بالمثمره للغايه لكنها في الوقت عينه تفعل
قوتها الاحتياطيه بل ويضع قاده جيوشها
خططا للتدخل العسكري
بغض الطرف عما قد يحققه تدخل كذاك في
النيجر فان مالي تنبه الى ان هدف بعض
الدول هو تفكيك مجموعه اكواس لعدم رغبتها
في اتحاد البلدان الافريقيه
ليست بلدان القاره وحدها من يتابع ببالغ
الاهتمام تطورات السابعه لانقلابات
الافريقيه في ثلاثه اعوام يقول البانتاجون
ان واشنطن ما زالت ملتزمه باعاده الامور
الى ما كانت عليه في النيجر وحل الازمه
بالطرق السلميه اما برلين التي تدعم جهود
الوساطه الاقليميه كما تقول فتطالب
بالابقاء على الضغط على المجلس العسكري
هناك من اجل عوده النظام الدستوري ماذا
الان عن باريس التي تتخذ من النيجر نقطه
ارتكاز استراتيجيتها الامنيه في منطقه
الساحل
[موسيقى]
مازلنا نسمع من المسؤولين الفرنسيين
تهديدات لقاده انقلاب النيجر بالتدخل
عسكريا في حال عدم اطلاق سراح الرئيس
المحتجز محمد بازوم فهل بات ذلك التدخل
وشيكا
الاذاعه الرسميه الجزائريه ذكرت ان
الجزائر رفضت طلبا فرنسيا باستخدام مجالها
الجوي في عمليه العسكريه ضد جارتها النيجر
لكن سريعا نفى قائد اركان الجيش الفرنسي
ان تكون بلاده قد قدمت مثل ذلك الطلب
ومعنا من اديس اببا موسى شيخو الكاتب
والباحث في شؤون الاتحاد الافريقي اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد شيخو هذا القرار لمجلس السلم
والامن التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي ما الذي
يمكن ان يؤثر في الاوضاع في النيجر تحديدا
نعم
مرحبا بك استاذ محمد وباستاذ المشاهدين
القرار الافريقي هو يعني قد يفعل الكثير
في حصار المجموعه الانقلابيه
واثنائها عن
الاستيلاء على الشرعيه من دون وجه حق
ويبقيها في عزله تامه خاصه ان دول مجموعه
غربي افريقيا
اكواس نشطه جدا
لتشديد وطئه الحصار على النيجر وخاصه ان
هذه المنطقه منطقه الساحل منطقه غير
مستقره والبلدان المجاوره ايضا كذلك
والنيجر تعيش سبعين بالمئه تقريبا على
المعونات الخارجيه
وحصار النيجر او المجموعات الانقلابيه
التي استولت السلطه ربما حتى لو لم يكن
على المدى القريب
يعني
سيضغط او سيسبب في عوده النظام الدستوري
وليس بالضروره ان يعود الرئيس
المعزول الشخصيا ولكن عوده البلاد الى
الدستور الى النظام الديمقراطي
سيتحقق ولو على المدى الطويل ولكن المدى
الطويل غير محبد لان مفوض شؤون السياسيه
والسلم والامن في الاتحاد الافريقي قال
لابد ان يتم ذلك في اسرع وقت ممكن حتى سنه
لسنا مستعدين للانتظار
لا اعتقد ان ذلك يكون في اسرع وقت لان
اجراءات الاتحاد الافريقي هو اخف الضرر
والتدخل العسكري ايضا له اشكاليات كبيره
عكف الاتحاد الافريقي على دراسته يعني
عميقا
ومجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي كان من
المفترض ان يتخذ هذه الاجراءات من اول
حدوث الانقلاب لكن التدخل العسكري له
اشكاليات عديده ذكرت بعدها من ان هذه
المنطقه غير مستقره وكلفه الحرب
وايضا هناك بعد عرقي وقبلي موجوده في داخل
النيجر فاذا تم التدخل العسكري ربما سيفجر
ذلك ازمه قد لا تقتصر على النيجر فقط ربما
ربما لهذا السبب ربما لهذا السبب يعني
عفوا ربما لهذا السبب الاتحاد اوصى بدراسه
كل التداعيات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والامنيه لمثل هذا التدخل هل يمكن ان يوحي
ذلك
لقاده الانقلاب في النيجر بان التدخل
العسكري في النهايه ليس محبدا
يعني التدخل العسكري ايضا ليس مستبعدا
وخاصه اشاره بيان المجلس الامن والسلم
الافريقي الى دراسه
الوضع لكن
مشكله النيجر هي مشكله الصراع النفوذ
فتجاذب الاطراف الدوليه هناك فرنسا هناك
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك
روسيا
الصراع على النفوذ في المنطقه ايضا اثر
على قرارات الاتحاد الافريقي وعلى
الدول الاكواس هناك اطراف تريد التدخل
العسكري والحسم بالقوه وهناك اطراف يعني
تدين في الانقلاب في بياناتها لكنها في
ارض الواقع لهم اتصالات لهم زيارات حتى
بعد
ان استولت المجموعه الانقلابيه على السلطه
هناك مبعوث رفيع المستوى للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه رفض وصل الى النيجر هذه الامور
هذه التجاذبات هي التي شوشت على الاتحاد
الافريقي كغيرها من القرارات يعني صحيح ان
هذه التدخلات ان هذه
القرارات لا تفيد كثيرا وليست ناجعه لكنها
اقل ما يمكن ان يفعله الاتحاد
الافريقي شكرا جزيلا لك موسى الشيخ من ادي
سببا
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
حيث قال مصدر في حركه حماس للجزيره ان
منفذي عمليه الخليه التي وقعت يوم امس قرب
مستوطنه كريات اربعه ينتمون الى الحركه
وكان جيش الاحتلال قد اعلن انه اعتقل
منفذي العمليه التي اسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنه
واصابه مستوطن اخر هذا وقد خلص اجتماع
للطاقم الامنيه الاسرائيليه المصغره
المعروف باسم الكبد الى تفويض رئيس
الوزراء ووزير الدفاع بتنفيذ قراراته
الراميه الى توجيه ضربات لمنفذي العملين
العمليات ومساعديهم وممولهم
تعتقل اسرائيل منفذي عمليه الخليه
الجنوبيه الضفه الغربيه كما تقول بعد
ساعات من اطلاق النار على سياره وقتل
مستوطنه واصابه اخر لكن جيشها لم ينجح حتى
الان في الوصول الى منفذ عمليه حواره
شماليه الضفه التي قتل فيها مستوطنه ما
يشغل اسرائيل اكثر هو البحث عن طريقه لوقف
الهجمات المكثفه على المستوطنين في الضفه
الغربيه منذ بدايه العام قتل 35 مستوطنا
اسرائيليا مقابل 33 قتيلا في العام الماضي
كله تتركز العمليات الفلسطينيه على
المستوطنات والطرق الالتفافيه التي يسلكها
المستوطنون للتنقل بين مستوطنات الضفه تلك
طرق التهمت مع المستوطنات والجدار الفاصل
اكثر من ثلث مساحه الضفه الغربيه هناك
يعيش اكثر من 700 الف مستوطن يحميهم اكثر
من 25 الف جندي اصبحوا في العامين
الماضيين اكثر الاهداف سهوله للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه لكن اسرائيل ترى ان خلف رصاصات
المقاومين الفلسطينيين قرارات ودعم يمتد
من خارج الحدود وفقد تهديدات الرسميه
الاسرائيليه فان ايران ضالعه بما يجري
تخطيطا وتمويلا وهذا يعني وفق التقديرات
الامنيه الاسرائيليه ان ما يجري ليس موجه
عمليه فرديه بل هجوم المنظما وعليه فان
اسرائيل لا تخفي قلقها من زياده التوتر في
مساحات اخرى بعيده عن المستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه وفق وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
فان حكومه نتنياهو تخطط للرد على هذه
الهجمات عبر ضرب اهداف خارج الحدود تلتفت
الانظار حكما الى حزب الله ومن خلفه ايران
ويتوقف التوتر على الحدود بين لبنان
واسرائيل ولا اشارات حتى الان على احتمال
تراجعه اذا ما اخذ بالاعتبار تسلسل
الاحداث بدايه في اسرائيل بان منفذ عمليه
من جدو قبل عده اشهر اخترق الحدود
الشماليه وما تبع ذلك من مناوشات على طرفي
الحدود لم تتوقف معها ازمه خيمتي حزب الله
ولا التوتر في قريه الغجر الحدوديه كذلك
تبدو حماس في قطاع غزه متاهبه لسعه الصفر
مع استمرار محاولاتها في تطوير قدراتها
العسكريه لا سيما المسيرات لكنها لم توقف
عملياتها في الضفه الغربيه واخرها عمليه
الخليل وفقا مصدر في الحركه للجزيره
تتوقف كذلك التهديدات المتبادله بين طهران
وتل ابيب اذ ترى اسرائيل ان ايران
وحلفائها في الاقليم يخططون وينفدون كشبكه
واحده يجب ضربها كل ذلك في ظل ازمه سياسيه
داخليه تتشعب في اسرائيل لتصل الجيش بقوه
الاحتياط وسلاح الجو هكذا يبدو ان اي
مواجهه واسعه مقبله ستكون صعبه للغايه على
تل ابيب كما يرى مسؤولها السابقون ومحللها
الامنيون
الان من الناصره الدكتور سليم بريك الخبير
في الشؤون الاسرائيليه والمحاضر في العلوم
السياسيه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور هذا التخويل
من الكابينه لرئيس الوزراء ووزير دفاعه
باتخاذ الخطوات الضروريه كما قيل
لمجابهه منفذين العمليات ومن يقف وراءهم
وممولهم من المتوقع منها
مساء الخير ولاني يعني اذا نحن بنبدا
بتصريح نتنياهو لما قال بانه هذه العمليات
موجهه من ايران باعتقاده انه هذا يدل على
افلاس لهذه الحكومه نتنياهو عمليا يعترف
بانه لا توجد لديه ادوات حقيقيه لمعالجه
هذا الموضوع
خلينا ناخذ في الحسبان كمان انه هذه
العمليات يعني ما هي اولا السلاح موجود
بكثره في الضفه الغربيه ولكن ما يحرك هذه
العمليات هي عمليا الدوافع والدوافع
توفرها حكومه اسرائيل ومستوطني اسرائيل
الان الكابينات انعقد اليوم نتنياهو
باعتقادي كان مضطر لعقد هذا الكابينات
لانه كان تحت ضغط شديد من قبل ممثلين
المستوطنين الاجهزه الامنيه توصي بثلاثه
امور مركزيه الامر الاول تقويه السلطه
الفلسطينيه
دفع الاموال المستحقه للسلطه الفلسطينيه
او على الاقل قسم كبير منها الموضوع
الثاني تحسين اوضاع الاقتصاديه لسكان
الضفه لتخ تخفف من الضغوط الامنيه والقضيه
الثالثه فتح بعض المعابر الان
المستوطنين ضد الاجهزه الامنيه يقفون بشكل
الان اصبح بشكل علني ضد الاجهزه الامنيه
ونحن نرى مثلا اليوم كان نقاش في
الكابينات لم يكن مهني نهائيا هذا النقاش
كان اولا جدال حاد بين وزير الدفاع الذي
اتهم المستوطنين بتاجيج الامور وبين
ممثلين المستوطنين مثل بين جفير وباقي
المركبات الفاشيه في الحكومه وهذا ما يصعب
على نتنياهو اتخاذ قرارات حكيمه هو
والاجهزه الامنيه التي في نهايه المطاف
تريد ان تخفض من حده التوتر كما وعدوا
الامريكان ولكن الان مع هذه الظواهر
الموجوده من المستوطنين الذين يعتمدون على
الفلسطينيين ومن ممثلين مستوطنين في
الحكومه نحن نرى بان هناك محاوله للهروب
لمحاربه حماس او ما يسمى
مرسليه حماس او داعمي حماس والقصد ايران
ولكن ني لا اعتقد بان اسرائيل ستضرب
ايران مثلا في لبنان او حماس في لبنان انا
لا اعتقد بان هذا سيحصل ولكن اسرائيل قد
تذهب الدكتور يعني معذره في مناطق الضفه
الغربيه نفسها قد تذهب الى عمليه عسكريه
واسعه في الضفه كما يطالب بذلك بعض
الوزراء هل يمكن ان تصل الامور الى هذا
الحد
باعتقادي نعم يعني هذه الحكومه حكومه
تصعيديه من تركيبتها نحن نرى بان القوه
الفاعله في هذه الحكومه هي قوه تصعيديه
تمثل المستوطنين والمتطرفين من المستوطنين
بينما الاجهزه الامنيه الان تقف عمليا
يعني بشكل ضعيفه امام هذه التوجهات ومن
الناحيه الثانيه تركيبه الكابينات نفسها
اصبحت تركيبه غير متوازنه يعني نتنياهو
باعتقاد وربما المسؤول عن امن القومي صحيا
يريدون تخفيف حده الامور ولكن في قلب
الكبرينات حتى وزراء من الليكود متشددين
ومؤيدين للمستوطنين من اسباب مختلفه وليس
بالضروره اسباب امنيه ولذلك قد يكون تصعيد
باعتقادي في نهايه المطاف سيكون الكثير من
العقوبات الجماعيه في الضفه الغربيه
وقد يحاولون احتواء هذا الموضوع بهذه
الطريقه وربما ايضا باتهام السلطه
الفلسطينيه والضغط عليها ولكن لا ارى
امكانيه للقيام بعمليات خارج حدود اسرائيل
هناك ايضا دعوه من كثير الى الى عمليات
اغتيال والتجديد على الاسرى هل هذا ايضا
وارد تماما
اولا يعني هناك تصعيد ضد الاسرى في السجون
الفلسطينيه منذ تولي بنجبير هذه الوزاره
يعني هذه الحكومه عمليا تشعل النار تقريبا
في كل مكان في الضفه الغربيه في السجون
حتى ضد المواطنين في دوله اسرائيل يعني كل
مكان هذه الحكومه تقوم بتاجيج الاوضاع
لانها حكومه انقلابيه بتركيباتها هذه
حكومه تركيبتها فاشيه تركيبتها غير
ديمقراطيه وتركيباتها تركيبه تكريس
الاحتلال ولذلك نحن نرى بانه لا يوجد هناك
افق مثلا على سبيل المثال رؤساء
الاستخبارات العسكريه كتبوا وثائق واوراق
يقولون فيها بانه لا يمكن حل هذه المشاكل
من غير ان يكون هناك افق سياسي للشعب
الفلسطيني ولكن مع هذه الحكومه لا يمكن ان
يكون هناك افق سياسي او مفاوضات او شيء من
هذا القبيل ولذلك سنرى تصعيد مع الوقت
وزياده من الاتهام للفلسطينيين واتهام
للسلطه الفلسطينيه بطبيعه الحال شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور سليم بريك من الناصره
[موسيقى]
في السودان حسم الجيش جدل الصراع على مقر
سلاح المدرعات في الخرطوم معلنا سيطره
قوته عليه بعد معارك داريه مع قوات الدعم
السريع استمرت لثلاثه ايام تصريح ياتي
خلافا لاعلان سابق للقوات الدعم السريع
بالسيطره على ذات المقر على جبهه اخرى
عاشت ام درمان اشتباكات عنيفه بين الطرفين
خصوصا بمحيط سلاح المهندسين في حين حذرت
الامم المتحده من تبعات الحرب على الوضع
الانساني ونزوح الالاف خصوصا من نيالا
عاصمه جنوب دارفور
قد تكون الاشتباكات الاعنف منذ بدء الحرب
في السودان بين قوه الجيش وقوه الدعم
السريع تركزت في معسكر المدرعات في منطقه
حي الشجر الجنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم خاصه
في الاتجاهين الشرقي والجنوبي وتحدثت
مصادر في الجيش السوداني عن تسلل قوات من
الدعم السريع من الناحيه الشرقيه لكنها
الصدت لاحقا بعد تكبيرها خسائر فادحه في
الارواح والعتاد وفق تصريحها تنافق ذلك مع
قصف من قوه الدعم السريع بالمدفعيه
الثقيله وتحليق وقصف الطائره العسكريه
السودانيه لمواقع للدعم السريع وسط تدرب
في التصريحات
قوه الدعم السريع سيطره افرادها على كامل
معسكر المدرعات وثبت مقاطع فيديو لهم وهم
يتجولون داخل المعسكر مشكله الى سيطرتها
على مدرعات واسلحه وذخائر مختلفه لكن
الجيش السوداني اعلن السيطره قوته على
معسكر سلاح المدرعات في الخرطوم بعد معارك
استمرت ثلاثه ايام 22
اليوم الساعه 3:12 السيطره سيطره سلاح
المدرعات
الله اكبر سجل متبادل اذا بشان الاستيلاء
على مقر سلاح المدرعات بالعاصمه السودانيه
الذي يشهد منذ ايام معارك ضاريه بين الجيش
وقوه الدعم السريع التي تسعى للسيطره عليه
باعتباره اقوى اسلحه الجيش السوداني تبلغ
مساحته 20 كيلومترا مربعا ويبعد نحو 12
كيلومترا جنوب مقر القياده العامه ويضم
خمسه كتائب دبابات يقدر عددها بنحو 75
دبابه ومهبطا بديلا للطائرات ويعتبر
النقطه الاخيره الفاصله بين تمركزات
وامدادات الدعم السريع والقياده العملي
للجيش بعد سقوط كل من معسكر اليرموك
وقياده الاحتياطي المركزي جنوبي الخرطوم
في يد قوه الدعم السريع بالتزامن مع ما
يحدث في الخرطوم هجوم متزامن في ام درمان
واحتدام للمعارك مع قص المتواصل ومتبادل
في مواقع استراتيجيه يتعلق الامر بمحيط
السلاح المهندسين بالاهميه الاستراتيجيه
وحي الالتحاب المجاور له جنوبيه المدينه
كما سجل تبادل اطلاق نار كثيف باسلحه
ثقيله وخفيفه في احياء الجماير وابروف
شرقيه مدينه ام درمان والى دارفور وتحديدا
نياله عاصمه
تتجه الانظار فقائمه القتلى خلال ايام في
ارتفاع بسبب الاشتباكات تحدث مكتب منسقيه
الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه بالسودان
عن نحو 50 الف شخص فروا من منازلهم جراء
الاشتباكات في نياله ومن تبعات هذا الوضع
تعذر وصول الشاحنات الامدادات الانسانيه
الى المدينه بسبب القتال الدائري هناك وضع
انساني في نيالا وغيرها جعل ولايه النيل
الابيض الواقعه الجنوبيه العاصمه تستقبل
اكثر من مليون نازحين من الخرطوم وولايه
دارفور وكوردوفان جراء الحرب الدائره بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ومعنا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني المختص في
الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه اهلا وسهلا لو
بدانا بهذا
التفاوت في الروايات المتعلق بسلاح
المدرعات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
ماذا ترجح
هو في الحقيقه هذا الهجوم الذي سنته قوات
الدعم السريعه على سلاح المدرعات يعني يصل
الى الرغم ثلاثين في عدد الهجوم الذي
هجمته على هذا السلاح المهم كذلك
يعني في كل يوم تهجم في اكثر من موجه هذه
الطريقه التي
تنفذها انها تهجم بموجه اولى
اذا ضربت الموجه الاولى يكون عندها قوه
مستعده في مكان قريب ثم تهجم بموجه ثانيه
وهكذا لذلك تتفاوت الروايات لانه بعض
الموجات قد تصل الى السور قد تدخل الى
داخل المدرعات قد تصل الى تتقدم تتوقف
تتقهر من جديد لذلك تضاربت الروايات حتى
الان الوضع مستقر بالنسبه للجيش السوداني
لكن
انا اشرت كثيرا انه قوات الدعم السريع
ارتكبت عده استراتيجيات خاطئه والان تشعر
ان هذه الحرب يعني هي على وشك خساره الحرب
هذا الامر جعلها شرسه جدا في الفتره
الاخيره يعني
اصرارها على سلاح المدرعات وحده يعني هي
الان لا تهاجم الجيش في اي مكان اخر سوى
في سلاح المدرعه باصرار غريب واحد لرفع
الروح المعنويه لدى جنودها الشيء الثاني
هذا السلاح يعني يجعلها هي اول منطقه
عسكريه تستطيع ان تقول انها اسقطتها داخل
الخرطوم هي اصغت مواقع من قبل للجيش في
الاستراتيجيه في يعني في الاحتياط المركزي
لكن هذه ليست مناطق عسكريه اساسيه للجيش
لذلك جلبت يعني قوات النخبه تلاحظ انه
قوات نخبه من خارج الخرطوم حضرت وشاركت
يعني حتى في كلام انها من خارج السودان من
ليبيا من تشاد من غيرها من الدول من
النيجر حتى يعني حضرت وشاركت في معارك
اليوم اصرار غريب جدا على اسقاط المدرعات
اذا سقط المدرعات سترفع من المعنويات لدى
قوات الدعم السريع ستجلب لها المزيد من
الدعم من الافراد من خارج الخرطوم تستطيع
ان تتحرك في مساحه واسعه جدا بحريه هي
جنوب الخرطوم بعد سقوط المدرعات يعني عفوا
كل ما تقوله الان يجعل الدعم السريع مؤهل
في المرحله المقبله على ان يكسر شوكه
الجيش بهذا الوصف الذي تقوله الان اقوله
انا انه اذا استطاع اذا ان يصغت المدرعات
لكن هذه ليست نهايه المعارك بالنسبه للجيش
هذا التغيير نوعي واستراتيجي في العمليات
اذا سقطت المدرعات بيد الدعم السريع لكن
ليست النهايه ولا تعني سيطره الدعم السريع
على الخرطوم لانه الجيش نفسه يعني افشل
خطط الدعم السريع في 25 فرقه حول السودان
لم يستطيع
الدعم السريع حتى الان اسقاط ولا فرقه
واحده من فرقه الجيش السوداني ولم يستطع
ان يسقط ولا منطقه عسكريه داخل الخرطوم
بما فيها المدرعات حتى اليوم
الان هم يصرون على اسقاط المدرعات بهذه
الشكل استراتيجياتهم الخاطئه قادتهم انهم
منذ الرابع من يوليو تحولت الدعم السريع
الى ما يشبه الدفاع داخل الخرطوم لكن هذه
فتره طويله يعني كان ينتظر هجوم وتحرك من
الجيش منذ الرابع من يوليو وحتى الان هذا
التحرك من الجيش لم يحصل اعطى الدعم
السريع فرصه لان يرتب
اوراقه يعيد ترتيب جنوده ويركز على نقطه
واحده فقط هي المدرع ات يحشد لها جنوده من
كامل الخرطوم كلمه في النهايه بسرعه لو
سمحت الوضع الانساني خاصه في فينيال فعلا
خطير للغايه نعم صحيح خطير للغايه هي في
كل مدن دارفور فشل الدعم السريع ان يستولي
على حاميات الجيش الكبيره على الفرق
الكبيره اذا كانت في الفاشر الضعين اصلا
لم يسقط فيها معارك في الجنينه نفسها هو
ارتكب مجازر ضد المدنيين ولكنه لم يستطع
اصغاض حاميه الجيش ولا فيزا الان نياله
نفس الشيء كانه ينتقم من المدنيين داخل
نياله بسبب انتصارات الجيش الكبير جدا من
الفرقه 16 داخل نيالا على الدعم السريع
يعني كان يظن انه يستطيع ان يصف نيالا
وبها مطار وتكون يعني ما كان للانداد الذي
اقوله انه هذه الحرب طالت ليس فقط
باصرار الدعم السريع على هذه الحرب لكن
لانه في اطراف دوليه تصر على اطاله الحرب
في السودان شكرا لك دكتور اسامه عيدروس
شكرا لك شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلنت سلطات القرمه المواليه لموسكو
استئناف حركه المرور على جسر القرم وكانت
حركه المركبات على هذا الجسر قد علقت لوقت
قصير بسبب وجود تهديف باستهداف محتمل من
جهتها قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انه تم
اعتراض طائرتين مسيرتين كانتا في مهمه
استطلاعيه في منطقه شبه جزيره القرم
اما في موسكو فقد اعلن حاكم العاصمه اسقاط
مسيرتين اوكرانيتين في اليوم الذي اكدت
فيه كياب تحقيق نصرا في جبهه زبروجيا
بدخول بلده روبوتين الاستراتيجيه كذلك
اعلنت القوات الروسيه تصدى ثلاث هجمات
بريه على محور دونيتسك شرقا اما سياسيا
فقد كشف مصدر اوروبي عن تحضير منسق
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل لمحادثات في نيويورك بشان
السلامه في اوكرانيا الشهر المقبل
الدخول الى قريه روبوتين الاستراتيجيه
هكذا ارادت القوات الاوكرانيه ان تصوره
انتصار في معارك الهجوم المضاد وتحديدا في
خط المواجهه بسبولوجيا
من المبكر اخماد هذه الجبهه المهمه لجميع
اطراف النزاع في السر يشكك اقرب حلفاء
اكياف في نجاح الهجوم المضاد الذي بدا
مطلع يونيو الماضي لكنها الحرب وليس كل ما
يقال في الكواليس يشعر به في العالم
والصراع الذي لا يعرف هدنه منذ 18 شهرا
يستعير في الجبهات المشتعله ويراد له ان
يتعدى حدود اوكرانيا الى داخل العمق
الروسي اعلن حاكم موسكو اسقاط مسيرتين
اوكرانيتين غرب العاصمه الروسيه وشمل
غربها حديث عن اضرار في احد المباني
السكنيه بسبب تحطم الطائرتين من جهتها
اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تصدي دفاعاتها
لمسيارتين في مقاطعه بريونسكا الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا وافشال عمليه التوغل داخل ترابها
على الارض الاوكرانيه وبحسب سلطتكيف
استهدفت القوات الروسيه ما لا يقل عن 30
قريه وبلده في مقاطعه زابوروجيا خلال
الساعات الاخيره الماضيه بنصر دبلوماسي
اخر يتبهر رئيس فلودي ميرسي ماذا سيقدم او
يؤخر اعلان مشترك بتوقيع احدى عشره دوله
من البلقان اعرب القاده عن دعمهم الثابت
لاستقلال اوكرانيا وسيادتها ووحده اراضيها
ضمن الحدود المعترف بها دوليا ومواجهه
العدوان الروسي كان ذلك في قمه باثنا
حضرها الرئيس سليمسكي وهو سعيد بما حصل
عليه من وعود اثناء جولته الاوروبيه التي
شملت السويد والدنمارك وهولندا تعهد له
ايضا رئيس الوزراء اليوناني كرياكوس ميتو
تاكيس بالمساعده في تدريب طياري مقاتلات
16 الاوكرانيين واعاده اعمار اوديسا بين
الدعم المتناهي بالسلاح وغيره والرغبه في
عدم اطلاق اخر رصاصه على الجهود
الدبلوماسيه يتارجح الموقف الاوروبي
تصريحات ممثل الاعلى للسياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد قبل ايام قليله كانت بدرجه
الرسائل وايضا ردود مبطنه وفق بوريل تريد
الدول الاوروبيه التوصل الى مفاوضات سلام
بشان اوكرانيا مؤكدا في نفس الوقت ان رفض
تسليح اوكرانيا لن يجلب السلام كلام
الاوروبيين عن المفاوضات مجرد تكتيك لمنح
القوات الاوكرانيه المنهكه وقتا لاستعاده
انفاسها هكذا علقت موسكو الحرب المفتوحه
على كل انواع الاسلحه والصفقات
الدبلوماسيه
العابره للقارات حتى قبل ان تضع اوزارها
غيرت خريطه التحالفات وقد تغيرها اكثر
قد اكدت سفيره الاوكرانيه في الاردن ان
مده المعركه في اوكرانيا ستعتمد على الدعم
الذي يقدمه شركائه كياب كالولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي وشددت سفيره الاوكرانيه
على ان هذا الدعم سيستمر في
سيستمر في المستقبل وفي ردها على سؤال
للجزيره خلال ندوه نقاشيه عقدها مكتب
الاتحاد الاوروبي في عمان قالت المسؤوله
الاوكرانيه ان استعاده 200 كيلومتر مربع
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه امر هام وفيه كلفه
عاليه على الطرف الاخر
انطلقت القمه الخامسه عشره لمجموعه الكبرى
الاقتصادات الناشئه المعروفه باسم بريكس
وذلك في مدينه جوان سبورت بجنوب افريقيا
بحضور نحو 50 زعيما ويشارك في هذه القمه
قاده كل من الصين والهند والبرازيل وجنوب
افريقيا بينما القى الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الذي يغيب عن القمه القى
كلمته عبر الفيديو وتناقش الدوره الحاليه
بلفات عده على راسها تم بحث انضمام مجموعه
من الدول التي تقدمت بطلبات فعليه
للانضمام الى هذا التكتل
وقد قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
دول مجموعه تخطت مستوى دول السبع من حيث
قدرتها او من حيث القدره الشرائيه واضاف
بوتين خلال كلمه متلفزه امام منتدى اعمال
بريكس في جهاز بول ان دول المجموعه تسير
في عمليه التخلي عن الدولار في اطار
التعامل المتبادل
دول
الطرق
دول اتحاد يعيش فيه اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات
وصلت في اطار الناتج العالمي الاجمالي الى
نحو 26% ومن حيث مقارنه القوات الشرائيه
فان الدول الخمسه تتجاوز مجموعه السبع اما
عمليه التخلي عن الدولار في العلاقات
بيننا فهي تكتسب اهميه كبيره وهي عمليه لا
رجعه فيها كما يتم بذل الجهود في مجال
العمل على اليات فعاله للتسويات الماليه
والرقابه الماليه على العملات الصعبه لذلك
فان حصه الدولار في عمليات التبادل
التجاري في نطاق بريكس اخذه في التناقص
توسيع عدد توسيع عدد دول هذه المجموعه
مؤكدا ان طلب دول جديده الانضمام الى انما
يدل على الاهميه المتناميه للمجموعه على
المستوى العالمي
في هذه القمه سيبحث القاده مساله توسيع
منظمه عدد من الدول ومنهم من يحضر معنا
القمه تسعى للانضمام لعائله بريكس وهو امر
يقدره على اعلى المستويات لانه يظهر ويؤكد
اهميه بريكس وتاثيرها المتناميه عالميا
سناخذ بالاعتبار جميع الطلبات التي امامنا
من اجل الوصول لقرارات تساعد المجموعه على
النمو
هذا وتسع قرابه واربعين دوله من بينها
الجزائر ومصر والسعوديه ودول عربيه وشرق
اوسطيه للانضمام لمجموعه بريكس التي تاسست
عام 2009 وتضم خمسه دول هي روسيا والهند
والبرازيل وجنوب افريقيا والصين
بدات مجموعه بريكس تجمعا اقتصاديا دون ان
تغيب عنه الرؤيه السياسيه بالكامل انطلقت
باجتماع عقد في روسيا وتشكلت بدايه باسم
بريك عام 2009 من الصين وروسيا والبرازيل
والهند لتنضم جنوب افريقيا وتتخذ المجموعه
اسمها الحالي براكس
تركزت اهداف بريكس على تحقيق نمو اقتصادي
وتعزيز التنميه والامن والسلام لتحقيق
الاستقرار السياسي والاقتصادي واصلاح
المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه وتفعيل التجاره
الدوليه
والاستثمار وتفعيل تبادل العملات المحليه
بين دول المجموعه وانشاء سوق المشتركه
للتجاره وعمله موحده في محاوله للخروج من
اشتراطات صندوق النقد الدولي التي تصفها
المجموعه بالمجحفه بدات بريكس بطرح ما قد
يكون بدائل للنظام الدولي الذي تهيمن عليه
دول الشمال فرغم انها تضم
42% من سكان العالم الا ان اعضائها الخمسه
لديهم اقل من 15% من حقوق التصويت في
البنك وصندوق النقد الدوليين مقابل نحو
17% للولايات المتحده وخمسه
لمجموعه السبع
تستحوذ دول المجموعه على اكثر من
31% من الناتج الاجمالي العالمي بحجم
اقتصاد يتجاوز اربعه واربعين تريليون
دولار مقابل اكثر من 30% من الناتج
الاجمالي العالمي لدول مجموعه السبع وحجم
اقتصاد يقارب واحدا واربعين تريليون دولار
تسهم دول المجموعه بنحو
23% من الاقتصاد العالمي ونحو
18% من تجاره السلع العالميه تنتج دول
المجموعه 30% من السلع والمنتجات عالميا
وتتحكم بخمسين في المئه من احتياطي الذهب
والعملات وتنتج المجموعه ما يزيد على 40%
من مصادر الطاقه العالميه نقاط دفعت قرابه
اربعين دوله للسعي للانضمام للمجموعه ومن
بينها الجزائر ومصر والسعوديه ودول عربيه
وشرق اوسطيه وسيشكل انضمامها محطه مهمه في
تحول موازين القوى الاقتصاديه العالميه
ولم تجد فكره انشاء مؤسسات دوليه موازيه
للمؤسسات الاقتصاديه الحاليه عن اجنده
المجموعه انشات بريكس بنك التنميه الجديد
براس مال قدره 50 مليار دولار ويسعى
للوصول الى 100 مليار دولار كما اسست
المجموعه صندوقا اطلق عليه صندوق
الاحتياطي النقدي يتضمن احتياطيات نقديه
طارئه بقيمه 100 مليار دولار تدعم الدول
لسداد ديونها وتسعد دول المجموعه الى
اقرار نظام دفع وتحويلات ماليه جديد متعدد
الاطراف والجنسيات ليشكل بديلا لنظام
الدفع الامريكي سويفت
مصادر محليه للجزيره بتجدد الاحتجاجات في
محافظه السويداء الجنوبيه سوريا وذلك على
ترد الاوضاع المعيشيه وقالت المصادر ان
السويداء سجلت اكثر من 35 نقطه احتجاج في
عمومه مناطق المحافظه وطلب المحتجون برحيل
النظام السوري ورموزه كما اغلق المتظاهرون
المؤسسات مدنيه وطرقات رئيسيه في عدد من
المدن والبلدات ياتي ذلك مع دخول الاضراب
والعصيان المدني في السويداء يومه الثالث
على التوالي
هذه الحناجر في محافظه السويداء جنوبيه
سوريا فتصدح من جديد مطالبه برحيل النظام
تكتسي الاحتجاجات اهميه وزخما مع تزايد
اعداد المحتجين في الساحات خاصه في ساحه
السير بمركز المدينه
[تصفيق]
اتسعت رقعه الاحتجاجات التي شارك فيها
رجال دين لتشمل 35 تجمعا في المحافظه
وريفها المحتجون رفعوا شعارات طالبت
بتنفيذ قرارات الامم المتحده التي تدعو
الى انتقال سياسي في البلاد
لم تكن الاوضاع المعيشيه كذلك بعيده عن
مطالبهم نحن الان امام مفترق طرق هذا
النظام عليه ان يرحل انتهينا وعلى الحكومه
قبل رحيل ان تتراجع عن كل القرارات اللي
عملتها بالغلاء اللي صار
المواطن اختنق ما عاد عنده قدره اعيش اذا
المواطن بده بالشهر اقل شهر بدي نقلتين ما
يحقن 200 الف ليره كيف بده يتعالج كيف اذا
مرض كيف بده يعلم اولاده واذا عنده ولد
بالجامعه
يؤكد المحتجون انهم مستمرون في حراكهم حتى
تحقيق مطالبهم
الاحتجاجات في السويداء اتخذت عده اوجه
اضراب شامله اغلاق المحل التجاريه بعد
اغلاق المؤسسات الحكوميه والعديد من المقر
التابعه لحزب البعث مع استمرار اغلاق طريق
دمشق السويد وتاتي الاحتجاجات على خلفيه
قرار الحكومه السوريه المتعلق برفع الدعم
عن سلع اساسيه
رفع رافقته زياده في الرواتب بنسبه 100%
لكن المحتجين يقولون ان التضخم بلغ اضعاف
الزياده على الرواتب عمر الحوراني الجزيره
من شمالي سوريا
[موسيقى]
ضمن فقره المتابعه في حصاد الليله نرصد
اهم ردود الفعل على قرار اليابان تصريف
المياه المعالجه من محطه فوكوشيما النوويه
في مياه المحيط الهادئ اعتبارا من يوم
الخميس المقبل فما القصه اولا تقع محطه
توليد الطاقه الكهربائيه النوويه
في بلده اوكوما التابعه لمقاطعه فوكوشيما
الواقعه الشرقيه اليابان المحطه عباره عن
مجمع يتالف من سته مفاعلات نوويه تعمل
بالماء الخفيف وتولد طاقه كهربائيه
مقدارها 4.7 جيجا وات الامر الذي يجعلها
واحده من اكبر 25 منتج للطاقه الكهربائيه
في العالم
في الحادي عشر من مارس اذار وقبل 12 عاما
وقع زلزال في اليابان زلزال كبير بقوه 8
درجات فاصل تسعه على مقياس رختر ادى هذا
الزلزال وقتها الى مشاكل تقنيه ادت الى
ارتفاع ضغط المفاعل ونتج عنه زياده في
النشاط الاشعاعي وبسبب ذلك امرت السلطات
اليابانيه باجلاء السكان ضمن نطاق بلغ 10
كيلومترات
منذ ذلك الحين تبحث اليابان عن طريقه
لتصريف المياه من المحطه النوويه وتضع
الخطط التي يراقبها الجيران والمنظمات
الدوليه لضمان عدم حدوث كارثه نوويه في
المنطقه بسبب تسرب تلك المياه الملوثه
وبالتالي الاضراب البشر هذا القرار اثار
ردود فعل اغلبها رافضه من الدول المجاوره
على الرغم من تاكيد طوكيو ان عمليه
التصريف المياه المعالجه من محطه فوكوشيما
في البحر ستستمر لسنوات ولن تكون لها اي
عواقب على البيئه او صحه الانسان
الخارجيه الصينيه استدعت السفيره
اليابانيه في بيجين على خلفيه هذا القرار
وحثت الحكومه اليابانيه على الغاء الخطه
التي تعتزم تنفيذها في المحيط الهادئ بجين
اضافت كذلك انها ستتخذ الاجراءات الضروريه
لضمان البيئه البحريه وسلامه الغذاء
والصحه العامه وفق تعبير المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه من جانبها قالت سلطات هونج كونج
انها ستفرد قيودا على واردات الاغذيه من
اليابان وفي المقابل اعتبرت كوريا
الجنوبيه ان خطه اليابان ليست فيها مشاكل
علميه او فنيه للمزيد ينضم الينا من اثناء
البروفيسور مارك
وهو كبير الباحثين في قضايا الامن النووي
بالمعهد الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه وهو
كذلك المبعوثه الامريكي السابق للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اهلا وسهلا بك بروفيسور
هذه الضجه والخوف هل له فعلا ما يبرر
كلا هذه المخاوف غير مبرره ابدا هذه
المخاوف هي محض
خطابات سياسيه من قبل
المسؤولين الصينيين الذين يودون ان
يستحدثوا مشكله سياسيه مع اليابان ان
الخطه القاضيه
بتصريف هذه المياه الملوثه درست بشكل
الدقيق من قبل الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه والتي قررت انه من الامن
وتلتزم اليابان بالمعايير الدوليه في هذا
التصريف هي فعلا الوكاله وافقت على ذلك بل
وتعهدت بنشر تقارير دوريه حول سير العمليه
للطمانه هل هذا كفيل بتهدئه الانفس
الحقيقه بكل تاكيد يمكن ان يكون هذا كافيا
لتهدئه ولكن نعرف انه عندما تودوا بعض
البلدان ان تستحدث مشكله سياسيه تقوم بذلك
ولكن هناك حقيقه اساسيه يجب ان نشير اليها
ان المحطات محطات طاقه في الصين وكوريا
الجنوبيه
صرفت مياه ملوثه في المحيط
وقاموا بذلك
اربع مرات
مستويات تركز من التريتيوم اربع مرات اكثر
من مستويات التركز في هذه المياه
اليابانيه وبالتالي يجب النظر في تاريخ
البلدان على المستوى المحلي في الصين وفي
كوريا الجنوبيه باضافه الى مقارنه ذلك مع
الدراسات على مستوى الوكاله الدولي ه
للطاقه الذريه لاتخاذ القرار ومع ذلك
بروفيسور منظمه جرين بيس مثلا اعتبرت الحل
الذي لجت اليه طوكيو حل خاطئ هل هناك فعلا
بعض المخاطر وان كانت محدوده
لقد فكرت بهذا الموضوع وفكرت بماهيه
المخاطر المحتمله حيث ان المياه عوجت بشكل
كبير وخففت بشكل اساسي وسوف ايضا تصرف بعد
ذلك في المحيط اذا ما كان هناك اي مشاكل
مرتبطه
بالزلازل سوف توقف اليابان هذه العمليه
وتخزن المياه في خزانات لذلك لا ارى حقيقه
لا ارى المخاطر اعتقد ان المنظمات من مثل
جرين بيس لديها معايير مثاليه بين مزدوجين
غير ممكنه في العالم الذي نعيش فيه اليوم
الصين مثلا
قاموا بحظر فوري على المنتجات البحريه
الاتيه من عشر مناطق في اليابان
هل هناك اي خطر ولو كان محدودا اقول مره
اخرى على الثروه السمكيه مثلا في تلك
المنطقه
امام المخاطر في الحقيقه ما من مخاطر
باستهلاكي الاسماك من تلك المنطقه بالنسبه
الى مستويات تريديوم سوف يكون هناك تركز
اكبر في الموز بالمقارنه مع السمك اذا
موزه واحده فيها تركز اكبر من
الاسماك في فوكوشيما وهذا امر مؤكد علميا
نتحدث عن مستويات اقل بكثير بالمقارنه مع
الموز على سبيل المثال ومع ذلك بروفيسور
طوكيو خائفه على سمعتها العالميه في مجال
الصيد البحري حتى انها خصصت 190 مليون
دولار
ليورو عفوا لمعالجه اي اثار تتعلق بالسمعه
هل من السهل ان تقوم بذلك
بالفعل لقد وضعتم الاصبع على الجرح الا
وهو السمعه هذه هي المشكله الاساسيه
بالنسبه الى اليابان وكما تفضلتم تركز
اليابان من خلال تخصيص موارد جمه لمحاوله
تحسين صورتها في مجال
السمك والمنتجات البحريه ولكن ذلك صعب
عندما يكون لدى اليابان خصوما في الصين
على سبيل المثال يقومون بهذه التصريحات
شكرا لضيفنا البروفيسور مارك في باتريك
كبير الباحثين في قضايا الامن النووي شكرا
جزيلا لك
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه حصاد هذه الليله دمتم في رعايه الله
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]